does writing energize you or exhaust you
both they they just kind of like hit you
and
um you know uh
i get really excited when um
i could create that world that gets me
really excited when i get the characters
alive
it exhausts me because i want it to go
faster than
than what where it's going um i
you know you want it sounds like
christmas you want christmas to come
right away you want to just
tear through the presents but it's um
you know and and you you come in
on all sorts of problems and you just
wish that
you could figure it out right away and
sometimes
you need that break though it's like how
come i didn't think about it yesterday
but today is so clear
this is what has to happen and and um
that that's exciting when i get that
it's frustrating when i couldn't think
about it that day
you know the answer to that you know
that question oh like oh that's a great
line that leads to this
or you know or maybe i should add this
action to it um so
it does energize me but it's definitely
frustrating
what is the most difficult part of the
writing process for you
yeah i like to always try to be like
honest
of of the the ability
of what i can do and you know you strive
to be the best
you can and uh like
i think the most difficult part is
because you want it to be so good
you're trying to figure out ways and
there's so many elements to that
is it this it's the story it's the
dialogue it's
it's the characters um and how that all
fits in
it's putting it all together it's
the difficult part is to make
each scene so good
that there is no bad scene so
if there is a bad scene you have to get
that scene out
so that how how do we get it
everything's so good that's
and that's the tough that's that's what
we're all trying to figure out right how
do we get the reader to turn the page
to keep turning the page it's when
it gets boring when it's when only gets
you know not interesting when there's
not a voice when the characters are
doing the same thing we've seen this
it's so so it's hard to find that
creativity that juice
to kind of you might have one great
scene but then the other
three are like average how do i get
those other three
from a three to a five you know how do i
get get it to a five
and that's the frustrating part like
dang is it the story or dang is it the
character itself or is it my stupid
dialogue
you know it's like that's the heart the
hardest part of it all the frustrating
part
um and that's what keeps you going
because you know you got one good scene
it keeps you know you're asking about
what energizes you oh man that was great
it felt
good it was gone then then the next
scene it comes to the dead hold and like
stop and like what did i just write
you know it makes no sense it's boring
it's it's
cliche it's now or never it's
i love you you know versus you know it's
easy to say
like show it show it on screen show the
thing
but to actually do it is that's the
craft and beauty of
what all these great screenwriters are
trying to do you know it's like
you see michael jordan shooting the
basketball but you don't see him
all those years of practice so so
you know we just try to get to work and
craft the scene
as best as we can and get better at it
and
and then finish the story and hop on to
the next one
did you watch lost dance i did yeah yeah
that's nice really fascinating yeah
behind this
yeah i always oh yeah i
love seeing everyone's process of of how
to do things
right right especially someone who's
very tenacious
[Music]
always and to you know and knows that
that's something in him that
he almost can't stop himself yeah
fascinating
yeah so you know it's
so you could have it you could have a
talent you could have all that
you could have a lot of different things
but i think what's
hard to teach is that obsessiveness you
know
why do you want to wake up it's easy to
sleep you know
easy to put it off to the next day um
so but you know because of the pandemic
and stuff we're all we're all going
through those questions
what you know like of of of
things what's important what do we want
to do what do we want to accomplish
how much time do we have things like
that i think
for me it was you know i
you know i made a decision i lost my mom
through breast cancer uh
15 years ago so that was the launch
of me going um i'm just gonna try it
and and and try try
something that um you know
i don't know what's gonna happen because
it's
easy to try things when you know what's
gonna happen
and uh still you know so i was like
i think being with her for those last
couple months of just trying to go like
and giving her saying go ahead it was
just i was like oh my gosh i could
go ahead and you know go ahead really
you were
you know i never had that kind of
freedom from
a parent her especially her because she
wanted me to um
you know do other things but
but then she finally knew and i i loved
that i was like i'm going to take this
and run and see
how far i could get you know so that's
uh
that's what kind of helped start it all
no
you know so my sort of pandemic
hit 15 years ago of going like oh
we're not giving tomorrow you know and i
i'm going to try as hard to get better
each day because i like doing it
you know i'm not going to waste time i'm
not going to waste a year
if i'm in a job that i didn't like
because i i'm not guaranteed next year
i kept that in my head so that's why i
had this
thing about time um just because of
my mom and so that that helped me
kind of like appreciate time and
appreciate
good and bad things you know i it's not
to say i want
to have everything being great but
it's just i want to live life you know i
want i don't experience it all i just
don't want to waste time
being unhappy i'd like to be unhappy
because i could feel it i just want to
spend two years on it you know
sometimes i feel like i'm living for two
people you know so you want to
experience
everything and you want it it's it's
just as simple as going outside
or taking the trash out so all the
things that
i would convince myself i um
that are you know hard or because i'm
lazy or
i was like even doing that i should just
be grateful for
you know going walking outside doing
this so if i have an opportunity
to write a script um that's luxurious so
i'm gonna i'm gonna
swing for the fences because you know
not given uh
tomorrow pretty much
you